[Music]
hi everyone my name is Roy and I'm very
excited to teach the workshop titled
advanced our markdown and I will be
joined by Michael lecturer Anderson Hugh
and I also will have two guest lecturers
Jenna gu and how to this will be a
two-day hands-on workshop primarily
based on our recent book or markdown the
definitive guide this work is designed
for those who want to improve their our
marketing skills in particular we will
talk about many low level details that
you probably don't hear very very often
for example how to tweak the appearance
of your HTML documents PDF documents or
Word or PowerPoint presentations so that
is about how to customize your are
magnum output in the second part you
will learn some existing our packages
including like flex dashboard for
creating - sports book down for writing
books blog thank you for building
websites package them for building
websites for your our practice and
articles were writing journal articles
and learner for building interactive
tutorials we will also talk about some
other features including how to use or
develop new and language engines meaning
that you don't have to use our in our
mechanic you can also use Python or C++
and we will also briefly talk about some
interactive components of our mock down
including HTML widgets and also shiny
documents I gave a three hour workshop
on this topic in 2017 in which I didn't
really have enough time to explain all
the details so this time I will be very
excited to show you a lot more details
in this workshop I really look forward
to seeing all of you at the conference
and I hope you will learn a lot
[Music]
you